so I just want to welcome everyone here
to the February 2023 New York open
statistical programming Meetup we are uh
clearly back to being virtual this month
we are going to work on going virtual in
a hybrid depending month to month
depending on our ability to find
speakers geographically and finding uh
venues to host us uh that's obviously a
bigger Geographic constraint so
um welcome to the virtual one it's nice
that we have um the virtual option now
to be able to ghost on months virtuals
so months in person
so the very first thing we're going to
do is ask about jobs
if you're hiring or you're looking for a
job
we obviously can't all jump in and
announce it up here so go to the NY hack
our slack and we can put the link
into the chat and go to NY hack our
slack and post your jobs there
um that's the best option for you right
now to go get a job and over the years
over the decades we have gotten many
people jobs simply by someone standing
up and saying uh whether or not you are
hiring and people have found great
employees and employees have found great
employers so it's really nice that
having this opportunity so please we
have a job go to NY hack R the slack
Channel or if you go to my hackard.org
you can find the slack Channel and go to
the job postings Channel and let us know
about your job
um since I am on camera I am hiring
um hiring for both part-time and
full-time data scientists data engineers
and sales whether you call an account
executive or Business Development or
sales whatever you like to call it we
want someone to work with customers to
help them out
all right so everyone has the jobs going
to go to my hackar.org find the slack
Channel and post a job
next up pizza we do this in person we
get to order pizza for you so my pizza
tonight it's been sitting in my house
for about 25 minutes so it's already the
cheese is congealed so you see this
pizza right here that's the crust for
the underside good cheese lock because
hey it has good cheese lock but bead's
been sitting around so tonight this is
from Jet's Pizza some of you may know
Jet's Pizza is a regionally famous pizza
chain from Detroit
um and they've opened a few outposts in
New York city so I've taken tonight's
opportunity to have this Detroit style
pizza which is having a real moment
right now in the pizza scene and
enjoying that here uh this is in honor
of Jeff Ryan of XTS Fame and Adam Hogan
of the IR New York t-shirts Fame
so thank you to both of those they're
both from Chicago and they love Detroit
style pizza and turn me on to Jets so
everyone else let us know where you're
where you're getting pizza from I see
there's already a few fans of jets in
the chat there that's great I'm glad
everyone loves Jets I I'm a big fan of
the place especially that garlic dip
um it's it's a great it's a great place
it's it's really tasty
so everyone else did you get pizza or
did you get some other food let us know
in the chat where you're eating from yes
food is a big part of this Meetup so let
us know
uh while people are letting us know I
will just do a few more announcements uh
we have a few conferences coming up that
this community is probably uh excited
about brownies nice brownies from
California cool enjoying them
um so enjoy your brownies
so a few conferences coming up in the
next few months there is data Council
taking place in Austin that's March 28th
through 30th if you want to buy a ticket
for that you can use code NY openstat20
it's in camel case I don't know if it's
case sensitive we will send that to the
chat oh I see Nicole already put that
into the chat you go to datacouncil.ai
Austin you can check out the conference
also coming up in a few months April
19th through 21st is d4con in Tampa
that's going to be taking place but
virtually and in person and you can use
code NY hack R to get 20 off that's the
same discount code you get for as much
as often as we can we try to use that
code getting people to use that code
Nicole just posted it in the chat NY
hack R for 20 discount go to
d4con.io to learn more about that
conference taking place April 19th
through 21st
and at the end of this Meetup after
David's talk after the questions we are
going to give away a free ticket to each
of those conferences to someone who is
attending tonight
don't worry if you're not here when I
say your name we will contact you but
I'll announce your name if your present
we'll give you a little uh we'll give
you a virtual golf class
um if you're not present we will be in
touch with you to give you your free
ticket so at the end of Davis talk after
the questions you'll get a free ticket
tell you what we're going to give a free
ticket to each randomly and to whoever
asks the best as determined by me
question of David uh you'll also get a
free ticket to to d4con all right and
David can help me uh figure out who
guessed the best question we'll figure
out some subjective way I'm sure
also conferences we all know and love
nyr nyr we have an announcement about
that coming up really soon the plans are
almost finalized so we'll let you know
about nyr coming up in a week or two
hopefully we'll have all the details
ironed out and we'll be able to tell you
all about that I'm really excited
I see a few more things in talking about
whether eating liver and onions with
parsley and Raleigh all right and then
we have best cheeseless pizza in the
Rockies home slice and Durango now home
slice and Durango is that related to
home slice in Austin because in Austin
the home slice is amazing
um I don't know about the one in Durango
so if it is let me know because I'd love
to see that
all right
um so someone's asking about do we have
a list of conferences throughout the
year that I recommend well of course
data Council coming up I recommend
um d4con in Tampa Mir which is will be
announced very soon Arc of if you're in
government I'm wearing the shirt right
now is coming up later this year we'll
have announcements about that our
positive conf is coming up odsc lots of
good conferences and we try to put these
things out for in our email blast as
they come up we get discount codes from
various conferences we'll try to send
them out to you as soon as possible
and like Nicole said uh sign up for
um if you remember the Meetup you should
be getting emails make sure you're
you're registered for the emails or
follow our stats AI on Twitter to find
out more
the meet up for the next few months
we have speakers lined up for March and
April but we don't necessarily have a
venue to host us and the speakers are
New York City based so please folks if
you have office space in New York it
could be confident room an auditorium
could be anything let us know contact me
on Twitter on LinkedIn go to
geralander.com contact message us on
slack to end my hack our slack anyway if
you have space to give us let us know
and we'll be very very happy to
um host the Meetup in your space so
anyone in a space in your city it could
be Midtown it could be downtown it could
be anywhere in between right let me know
and we will host it there
so
please let me know
in may we have the inverse problem we
have a space but no speaker lined up
quite yet so if you're going to be in
New York City in May or you live in New
York City in May and you want to give a
talk let me know uh because we have a
venue lined up but we just need to have
a speaker for it so
be in touch with me let me know uh if
you uh want to give a talk in your round
of May so you know that's the way this
Meetup works either someone says I want
to give a talk or I randomly call on
them to give a talk it can go anywhere
any direction it does happen
um in fact that's how David's here I
said hey you're giving a talk this month
he said cool I asked him I asked him I
gave him the courtesy of asking other
people
yes yes
so if you want to chat about the Meetup
because actually there's going to be
like a q a at the end which there always
is but especially today if you want to
be a part of this q a post the messages
preferably in our NY hack our slack
instead of Zoom because I said this
before I cannot copy and paste from the
zoom chat I don't know what's wrong I
have tried on two different computers so
go to NY hack R plus also the NY a hack
our slack is good better because it's
part of the community it's not ephemeral
like the chat here it'll be in the
community people can reference it at
least for another 90 days until the free
tier Zoom takes it away so if you're
looking for that I think Nicole just put
a link to the in my hack our slack go in
there and Beyond tonight you can ask
questions about R python Julia SQL get
there's channels for all that there's an
event Channel where we try to put
interesting events both ran by us and
ran by other people in the community
let's go there check that out
um I think it's a it's a very good
resource
and that goes also with our website
nyhacker.org if you go there you will
see there is what 13 years looking at
the date 13 years worth of talks up
there
a slideshow for every single talk that
we've ever had and videos for at least
half of them we didn't start recording
until you know a few years into the
Meetup so that's a really great resource
for learning about so much stuff
so lots of stuff for you folks to look
at conferences meetups pizza or other
food and be sure to chat
so when I thought when I when David
agreed willingly to come talk at this
Meetup I was really excited because I
thought he he spoken at our conference
our New York R conference and our our
government conference a few times
and I thought he had spoken at the
Meetup back in like 2009
it turns out despite coming to the
Meetup back in 2009 and in the years
since he has never actually given a talk
here and I was shocked when I found this
out because uh how has he not given a
talk at this Meetup
um he was using R before it was called R
that's how much of a hipster he is
he wrote the book oh hold on wait a
minute I have it right here
he wrote This Book
an introduction to r with a few other
people with Bill venables of legend in
the community and I will say I got both
of them to autograph this
now there's actually a story behind this
autograph
I asked Max and David to bring a
copy to Bill venables and get an
autographed for me
only one of them came back
so I'm still waiting for the other copy
that's why I did things I had a
redundancy to make sure I got a copy so
I'm very happy that I have this copy of
this book because this means a lot to me
having both these authors sign it
um so I'm very happy about that so thank
you David for signing seriously that was
a great book so folks maybe later he'll
tell you if he doesn't I'll explain why
how he's used R before is called R
um so I'm shocked he's never spoken at
this Meetup but I'm glad we have this
long-term member he's wearing one of our
NYC data Mafia t-shirts but yep there it
is because he is a longtime friend of
this community uh particularly a friend
of this Meetup so everyone please
welcome David Smith
thank you Jared it is awesome to be here
yeah thank you so much uh for being here
I'm so sorry I couldn't be there in
person I could have sworn that I had
spoken at that Meetup before because I
do have the T-shirt
um but I'm so glad I forget to rectify
that situation here and now
um
today I'm going to talk about co-pilot
and specifically using copilot for R and
if you haven't heard about copilot or
don't know much about it don't worry
because I will talk about what co-pilot
is what it does and how you can use it
um and even if you do know all about
copilots um I'm going to go behind the
scenes in this talk in quite a bit of
depth about how copilot works and
specifically how it uses generative AI
to produce the results that it does and
talk a little bit about a lot talk a
little bit about how generative AI works
so with that let me go ahead and Jump
Right In
hopefully my slides will progress if I
click the button there we go
all right so for those of you that
haven't heard of GitHub copilot before
it is a service provided by GitHub the
simplest you go to save all your source
code and and collaborate with other
Developers
and it's kind of like an AI pair
programmer that sits there and works
with you as your typing code it looks at
the context of the code that you are
actively developing
um the uh the comments around it the
lines of code around it even things like
the other files that you have on your
project and uses that information to
suggest the next step in your coding
practice so the example here comes from
the marketing team at GitHub it is a
typescript example you can see that the
somebody has started to write a function
in typescript and then suddenly copilot
suggests an entire implementation of
that function based on its name based on
the arguments and just around the
general context of that particular
example right there now copilot is one
of those things that is much easier to
understand if you can see it in action
rather than just seeing a static slide
like this
um so I have prepared a demo which I'll
show you in just a second but before I
get to the that when you're using
copilot you are using it within an
editor environment I use Visual Studio
code all the time um so I'll be
demonstrating it within vs code but you
can also use it within jetbrains uh
within Visual Studio the commercial
version and also uh within
um what's that last phone code I can't
remember I'll come back to it
um but like I said I use Visual Studio
code so that's what you're going to see
in this demo and if you if you're using
visual studio code and you want to
install it and get started with the
copilot there's a great link on your
screen right there that you can use to
get started and I'll share that link at
the end of this talk along with a whole
bunch of other resources that are
available in the GitHub repository you
can see on the bottom left hand side of
most of these slides
all right
so let's have a look at GitHub copilot
in action I do have a recorded demo here
and you can actually see that in the
GitHub repository as well and I have a
recorded repository a recorded version
of this demo because GitHub copilot like
most generative AI systems is not
deterministic it gives different results
every time
um so you've got to be pretty brave to
give a demo with it because it might do
things that you don't expect but I'm
feeling brave today so let's go ahead
and do a live demo and I'm going to
switch over to visual studio code
and you can see I have Visual Studio
code open I've got a blank R script open
and you can see I've got the r terminal
already live down there at the bottom so
I'm going to start and
I'm going to start live coding right
here
um I'm going to do an analysis of a data
set it's called the pumpkins data set
it's data set that it's a data set that
has information about various kinds of
pumpkin sales how much they sold for
what kind of packaging they are in the
quality the location all those usual
things and I'm going to try and build an
analysis live with github's help
so I'm going to use the Tidy verse to
prepare my data and dream the analysis
let's start off with Library tidy this
you can see copilot was just helping me
that gray part you saw there was copilot
making the suggestions you can see
there's a little icon down here on the
bottom right hand side about copilot
when that's spinning around it's busy
thinking about things to suggest
so let's start off with a comment read
in the pumpkin data
press enter and in just a second GitHub
is proposing me
a solution which I could accept just
simply by pressing tab now it's actually
suggesting to read a file direct from a
GitHub repository and this is because
this data set has been used and lots of
tutorials and examples on the web in
fact this particular data set comes from
the ml for beginners tutorial which is
available on GitHub and there's a link
in the talk notes for that in this case
I've got a local file so let's read in
from that pumpkins
thanks to Value read underscore CSV
and my file name is called us Dash oh
look copyle is actually selecting the
file name because it has the context of
my entire project to make suggestions
like that so let's go ahead and read in
that theater is read in
now if you have a look at the column
names
oops type properly here
um you can see they've got spaces in
them and there's a couple of columns
that don't even have names that's a bit
problematic for the analysis later on so
let's clean those up
let's actually use the janitor package
and you can see it's making suggestions
to use janitor there and I just want
something a little bit more simple than
that so I'm actually going to accept the
whole thing and just use the clean names
functions to clean up those names oops I
forgot to actually run Library janitor
there there we go
and so now if I run names pumpkins again
we can see that the names have the
spaces have been taken out
all right
um what do we do when we analyze data we
look at the data let's perhaps look at
display
five random rows for fun
all right GitHub is using the context
there to actually use the sample
underscore n function in a tidy verse
kind of a way and now we can see five
random rows from the data set
um the locations are like Columbia and
New York the varieties are 36 inch box
and a one and one ninth
um uh bushel package all kinds of things
we've got some prices there the low
price the high price at which it was
sold and we use we'll use that
information for the analysis have you
seen this kind of thing before Jared
have you played around
in your work
a little bit when it first came out I
tried using it it's pretty handy for
like
getting you like live scaffolding and
boilerplate so far for me all right cool
I caught you eating pizza didn't I that
was my goal you totally did that's why
there's a policy excellent all right all
right so now that we had a look at the
data um let's do something a bit more
complex let's create a table uh let's
show the average
high price
by package it's got a box that comes in
and it's color
enter GitHub thinks a minute it gives a
suggestion uh the suggestion is giving
to me is pumpkins into a group buy into
a summarize that looks about right I'll
press tab to accept that press enter and
there we go we got back a table and we
can see the 109 bushel cartons
um in the orange color the average high
price was 16.2 now by the way just going
back to the way the GitHub is a bit none
sorry co-piloted rather is a bit
non-deterministic a couple of times when
I was practicing a demo it actually
passed it into Knitter to generate a
nicely formatted table for me didn't do
it that time but like I said you never
quite know exactly which solution is
going to give you
all right so let's do some modeling how
about an analysis of variants
of high price
by by price by the verb ones we've got
an origin that's the origin color and
item size
enter GitHub is thinking foreign
underscore test that's actually not the
the function I want to use in this case
I want to use aov so let's guide it a
little bit model aov
you can actually see that coming up
already so we've got high price origin
color and item size notice that I didn't
put the specific variable names in my
comment there but it's again it's figure
things out by context
okay that aov is done and now let's
print out the analysis of very unstable
print aov table
okay it's suggesting summary model
that's what I would use too and there we
go we have the analysis of variance the
three variables are significant when it
comes to the higher price and there's
lots of other things we can do as well
we can do predictions and it's really
really helpful when doing these
suggestions and I'll give you a bit of a
confession it's actually quite a while
since I've actually done a statistical
analysis over there I
most of these commands since I had last
used them but as I was developing this
demo copilot it was super helpful is
actually suggesting idioms for me
um that I could use to do this analysis
so I hope that was a good example right
there
let me go back to my slides
all right
there's the demo in the slides which you
can find on the um on the coupon at our
website so now that you've seen co-pilot
in action uh let's talk a little bit
about how it works
and behind the scenes What's Happening
Here is a generative AI model is being
used to generate suggestions of code
from prompts which is the previous lines
of code that you have in your script but
let's talk about this a little bit more
General
now you might have heard of a company
called open AI it's been very much in
the news recently with things like chat
GPT
um there are three models in particular
uh that openai has developed for
generative AI
um one is gpt3 which is based around
text the prompts you give it like pieces
of text the example here is write a
tagline for an ice cream shop shop and
one response that it might generate for
you
from gpt3 is we serve up Smiles with
every scoop
and you probably heard about chat gbt
it's been in the news a lot lately and
in fact the new Bing uses something like
check GPT in the background that's also
based on a similar kind of model but a
more advanced version
another model that openai has created is
called codex and unlike gbd which is
basically trained on all the text in the
web
codex is trained on all of the open
source code in GitHub so it has lots and
lots of examples of code from lots of
different languages including R but also
has things like all the readme files and
the data files and lots of context that
helps it create responses to prompts
like create a SQL query for all the
customers in textist named Jane query
equals and then the response that codex
would give back to that like that is a
nice SQL query that does exactly what
you've asked select start from customers
where State equals TX and first name
equals Jane
the other model you've probably heard
about is Dali which unlike the other two
which operate on text this one generates
images from text
an example here is the prompt is a white
siamese cat and then the response might
be a picture of a picture of a Siamese
cat
I want to emphasize that this is not a
Web search type of a thing happening
it's actually generated that image on
the Fly and that image most likely
doesn't exist anywhere else on the web
it was generated when you asked for it
by that prompt there's lots to talk
about these image image generation
models but I'm not don't have time to
talk about any of them today so I'm
going to focus on gpt3 and codex as we
go forward
now you've um
let's go I'll come back to what I was
about to say but um let me talk a little
bit more about how generative AI models
work
everything starts with a prompt you've
seen a few examples just a minute ago
like generate a tagline for an ice cream
shop or that prompt might come from the
pieces of code that copilot is working
from in that context whatever that
prompt is it gets passed into a
generative AI model now for now just
think of that as a black box
input is the prompt it gets passed into
this Black Box model and then the output
is a completion or a continuation of
that prompt
so in the case of gpt3 that's some text
that completes the first prompt you gave
it in the case of codex that's in code
typically that completes the code that
you provided for it so that's the
fundamentals of how these generative AI
models work
now the way that they are built in the
first place is with lots and lots of
data and lots and lots of training data
um gpt3 for example has it's a neural
network with several billion parameters
that was trained on literal zettabytes
of data uh it took months upon months to
actually train this model
um millions of dollars of CPU hours to
actually generate that black box at the
end of the day it's not something that
people typically will do themselves but
companies like open AI have provided
these neural networks that you can then
pass in a prompt to generate a
completion
but they are black boxes and that
implies some properties of those black
boxes
um but first of all let's have a look at
what they can do and as we saw in a
minute these generative AI models can
generate texts images and code
and what they generate is really driven
by what they are trained on in the first
place and now we're seeing in things
like specialized generative AI models
that are trained on for example the
medical literature the design to
generate medical information to help
support people in the medical industry
the output that they generate you might
consider to be human-like it looks like
a human could have written it and that's
because it's trained on data that human
is written text and codes and so forth
but I want to emphasize the fact that
it's only human-like It's Not a Human
Action though it's just it's really a
probabilistic thing generate a likely
continuation of the prompts that you
gave me
conditional on the training data that I
was trained with on the first place
and you've seen a lot of examples of
people using generativity AI like chat
GPT to extract information you know ask
it a question you know what was the 22nd
president of the United States and the
continuation although the response that
it gives you is likely to be correct
because there's lots of information
about the 22nd president of the United
States in the web that it was trained on
and it's likely to give the correct
answer to that
in that particular case we'll have some
caveats about that in a minute
in addition to extracting information
um these generative AI models create
novel content it's not just a copy of of
what it was trained upon it's actually
generating new text new images and new
code that wasn't contained in its
training set and that has a lot of nice
implications for example you can use it
to do creative works you know write me a
poem write me a letter write me an essay
yeah we'll do those kinds of things you
can also do a thing for things like
translations like translate this bit of
text from English into French and that
works because it has uh text from lots
of languages and it's training set
English is the most representative one
because English is most represented on
the web so it doesn't do so well in
other languages but those translations
do work
so that's the things that it can do
let's have a look at what it is not
I want to emphasize that generative AI
is not intelligent it has no
intelligence it does not think it is
really just a predictive system you know
where all statisticians data scientists
machine learning people it really is
just predict from my prompt what the
most likely continuation is and that's
basic once again upon its training data
we've seen already that it's not
necessarily deterministic either unlike
traditional machine learning models
there's not just one single prediction
what it actually generates is a whole
series of potential predictions
associated with their probabilities and
as we'll see a little bit later on it
doesn't just choose the most likely one
it actually um randomly samples from the
top you know X percent depending on
certain settings so what that means is
you can give it the same prompt twice
and get a different response back each
time probably anyway
and one consequence of that is that
these generative AI models are not
trustworthy it's not regurgitating a
fact it's not generating information for
you it's simply making predictions of
what sequence of words best follows your
prompt given the training data and what
that means in turn is it can hallucinate
facts you know especially when you give
it a prompt that strongly suggests
things that are not facts
um you've probably seen a lot of example
stories on the web of AI Bots sort of
getting into conversations or arguments
with people and that's because it's
feeding on its own conversation which is
in turn is to say argumentative
and that provides what I'm sort of
talking about Killer Robots it's
probably because the prompt suggestion
suggested something to do with that and
then it's drawing on sci-fi literature
to continue its prompts because they're
the most likely things to follow on with
once you start talking about Killer
Robots
furthermore generative AI does not learn
remember it's a black box that model was
fixed at the time of its training and it
never changes again yeah we'll see some
examples of that in just a minute
also the Black Box does not contain all
the information of its training set and
you can think about that quite simply in
terms of the fact the internet is
several yottabytes of data
um but chat GPT itself or gpt3 you know
that's that's many many gigabytes of
data but it's certainly way way smaller
than the internet itself so in some
sense the information must be compressed
down
there's a really good paper not a paper
an article in fact it's for a late
audience but it's a horror highly
recommended it's called if you search
for the chat gbt is a blurry jpeg of the
web there's a link in the talk notes
linked on this slide it gives a really
good at um sort of Layman's explanation
about what's going on with that
compression process
um but a good way to think of it is
these models are a blurry jpeg of all
the information that was in its training
data
now the flip side to that is that these
generative AI models do not include or
contain verbatim copies of the
information or the files that are in its
training data it can generate
continuations from prompts that make it
looks like it might but oftentimes these
are just random Generations that look
like the stuff that it was really
trained on or sometimes it does generate
literal stuff that does exist somewhere
else that's because it's very highly
represented in the training data or
perhaps there's only one logical
completion from The Prompt that you
provided
I want to re emphasize these last points
generative AI doesn't understand
language it's just a predictive engine
it doesn't understand math either it
doesn't learn the rules of mathematics
and when offered when you give it math
problems like you know what is 3000 plus
some random number it'll get the answer
wrong because it's never seen that
particular sequence of characters in its
training set
by the same token generative AI doesn't
understand facts it might look like it
does because the predictions the
completions Echo information the
training set but that's by far and away
not guaranteed
gender of AI doesn't understand manners
it doesn't understand emotion that
doesn't understand ethics it doesn't
understand anything and it's one
recommendation it's really hard to avoid
but really try to avoid
anthropomorphizing AI systems don't talk
them out talk about them as he or she or
give them emotions or motives it's just
a predictive system based around a black
box
all that being said I've talked a lot
about some of the downsides of
generative AI you can mitigate some of
them with something called prompt
engineering and that can be an entire
seminar on its own right so I don't have
enough time to really go into that but
just very briefly you've got a lot of
scope for providing information that
prompts and in fact in gpd3 and you can
do more than a thousand words uh in that
prompt so for example you can give it a
prompt like extract the mailing address
from this email copy in an email and see
what it does and with that context we'll
actually scan the contents of that email
find the bit that looks like an address
and actually return the address back to
you and there are lots of other things
you can do with those prompts you can
tell it a style to generate its response
in like respond in the style of Liam
Neeson reciting a Valentine's poem
that's a fun one to do
um
and a lot of the um uh well I'll say I'm
gonna we've got to be looking at using
uh gpt3 through the API in a minute and
as a programmer using the API you're
fully responsible for generating this
prompt but if you're using communic
Commercial Services like chat gbt or the
new Bing a lot of prompt engineering is
happening behind the scenes that you
don't see what's being passed in that
blocks Box model is a lot of context
perhaps contacts from a web search or
contacts from your previous chat history
that might make it seem like the AI has
memory or has emotions but that's just a
function of what's gone into its prompt
not of the AI model itself
all right moving on there
so we've heard about open AI you might
not have heard that Microsoft has gone
into a partnership with openai to make
its models available within the Azure
service so if you use open AI as gpt3
that same model is now available with
Azure as is codex and as is Dali
although Dali is currently in preview
it's currently a little bit hard to get
access to there is a waiting list to get
access to these apis because demand is
way exceeded Supply on this but these
are exactly the same models now
available through the Azure service
which gives you you know all your Azure
security or you can use the same Azure
billing that you use for everything else
and combine that with all the other
Azure Services as well
okay
and that in fact is what co-pilot does
behind the scenes co-pilot is using the
open AI codex model which as a reminder
is trained on lots and lots of open code
from GitHub
and when you are typing in Visual Studio
code what is happening is Visual Studio
code is providing context back to the
copied Pilot service so the lines of
code around where you're typing and
information about the files that you're
working on and so forth and then that is
what is used to provide the suggestions
which then Visual Studio code presents
as a gray option to you in your file you
can press tab then to accept it and by
the way when you do press tab to accept
those suggestions that information goes
back to the copilot service to improve
future suggestions that it delivers to
you as you're doing your code
all right
so that's a lot of tirade about
generative AI I thought you might be
interested to see generative AI in
action and also to see it used from ah
so I actually wrote some descriptions
and functions to interface with the open
AI service and let's um play around with
those now
how are we doing on time Jared
we are pretty good I take so you've been
you've been at it for about
I'm trying to do basically 25 minutes
another 10 15. all right okay we got
time for a few demos here and there okay
so I should be able to see my visual
studio code screen again I found the
screen there
and what I have open here is an auto
script which you can find in the GitHub
rape repo
um I'm gonna use Hadley's new
httr2 library interface with the API has
some nice features and allows me to
build up the URLs for the endpoint and
also because I am actually rate Limited
in my particular subscription I actually
use the rate limiting features
um to control the way I interact with
the API service but anyway
you will need you need a key if you're
using Azure you can get the key from the
keys and endpoints section in your
deployment this script by the way will
also work with the regular open AI
service so if you have an account with
open AI you can use the same scripts
just with a different endpoint
and a different key of course
so I've extracted that endpoint yeah
from my Azure subscription
and I've got several deployments in
there and each deployment is a different
kind of model I'm going to be working
first with what what is called DaVinci 3
and that's the same as gpd3 in open AI
there are a few other models that will
play around around with as we'll see
when we get to them
let's start with DaVinci 3 as the model
so first of all I'm going to show you
just how to manually set up an
interaction with the API first of all
you've got to define the URL which is
going to be the endpoint so it's that
basic endpoint I showed you plus open AI
slash deployments then you add in the
specific model that you're going for so
I've made that a parameter here
then there's completions because we're
using the completions API to generate a
completion from a prompt and then
there's the API version you need in
there as well
so that defines my URL that I'm going to
send a payload to
this is where I Define the payload
there's lots of options here that
control how GPT works the main one
that's of Interest here is the one
called prompt in this case I'm going to
send hello world as a prompt to the GPT
service
so let's define my payload just as a
little bit of a Json in a string
combine the endpoint and the payload
together
and then rec.perform and rec.perform in
HTTP HT
lers package is the one that actually
sends it to the service and then we're
getting extract from the result
the completion dollar choices that's
where the actual prompt uh pops in and
it comes back here with hello my name is
John Dern I'm new to this website I'm
interested in learning more about
programming and Technology any advice or
tips will be greatly appreciated thank
you by the way hello Well turns out to
be a really useful first prompt to send
to the GPD service
um because it's really varied the
responses you get back even the lengths
vary a lot so if you want to try things
out hello world is a good place to start
let's do something a little bit more
interesting so I've encapsulated all of
that script that I just showed you into
a function which I've stored in a file
called openai.r exactly the same code I
just showed you with a little bit more
error checking and so forth in there
so let's start off with some of the
um fun things let's ask openai gpd3 to
tell me a joke so I send that to the
service it comes back with what did the
fish say when it hit the wall damn not a
very good joke
um let's ask us to tell us a dad joke
instead
um
response question what are the baby
corns say to the mama corn answer
where's popcorn
all right that's also a bad dad joke but
it's not its strength anyway I want to
show you some of those things we're
talking about before about some of the
problems that it can occur with these
models if I ask an AI gbd3 what is the
date today
foreign
that is obviously not true
so that it demonstrates a couple of
things remember these models are black
boxes and this black box was frozen some
time ago so it has no idea what today's
date is so when you give it that prompt
it's got nothing to do except
hallucinating exactly a response that
makes sense in terms of English syntax
but certainly is not a fact
and by the same token if I run that same
prompt again there is a very good chance
I'm going to get a different result and
indeed I did today is June the 8th 2020.
so that demonstrates these models are
frozen in time and they're
non-deterministic you can put in the
same prompt to get different results
all right we'll do some more with gpd3
in the middle in a minute rather but I
wanted to look at codex for a minute
so now the prompt I'm giving it is this
one Fibonacci takes the value function n
and everybody
say that that is
deliberately chose the less than minus
Arrow there for R because that gives it
good guidance that I want R is a
continuation to this
and the model I'm passing it into is now
called code DaVinci 002 and that is the
the Codex model so it's the same one
that copilot is using let's see what
happens when you do this manually and
prompt it directly
um open AI Fibonacci is function n and
you can see what gets back is what you
might expect somebody who is learning
programming in ah this is code a
recursive Fibonacci function as and in
fact this particular example is set up
to generate
um one to n Fibonacci numbers from that
in the loop when I run this differently
I get different responses sometimes it
just generates one Fibonacci number and
I've even got some examples of calling
that code down there at the bottom
because it just keeps on continuing with
what are the things it might see and
it's already seen things like that in
scripts before probably tutorials
teaching people how to run r
let's have a look at another couple of
examples with codex I'm going to prompt
it with a comment read data from a file
but that's all
and most likely this will not be R and
in fact it looks like it's generated is
that python I'm not sure exactly what
that is but it's generated just some
code in some language
um to read data from a file so let's
encourage a little bit more and give it
two lines of input
redated from a file data Arrow so this
is pretty clearly going to be r b and R
response
I mean against these to monitor CSV
example so you can see some examples of
how codex is actually generating those
problems with their Visual Studio code
but Visual Studio code provides back to
the co-pilot service a lot more context
which is what makes it prom its prompts
a lot better than these random type
things that we're getting right here
okay moving on to a couple more examples
going back to gpt3 again that's the text
example and let's ask it to write a
limerick with the latest version of gpt3
there once was a language called python
it was Quran to be trying it had an
interpreter to run your coder and a
community that was flying I get a
different response every time for this
one it's usually a pretty decent
Limerick this one Rhymes it's in the
right meter that's pretty good but it's
interesting to compare that with smaller
and older versions of these generative
AI models if I use text DaVinci too
that's actually the same GPT model but a
much smaller neural network and we can
it runs faster it's cheaper to run to
but if I run that one you can see what
we get back is and once was a language
called python its syntax was simple and
sweet but it didn't matter because it
was so slow that nobody ever used it
um obviously a different type of
Limerick it doesn't rhyme it's not as
factual you can see the differences
between using these simpler models and
in fact we can even go to a previous
generation of the GPT models that's the
Q Remodel and see what it comes back
with then
wow this isn't even a limerick it's a
poem with four lines I'm not going to
read all that it doesn't rhyme you get
very different things from these older
models as well one of these days I'm
going to sync this up with that video
from
um 2001 where sort of um the the
astronaut is pulling the bits out of how
and it slowly degrading until it starts
seeing Daisy same kind of thing is
happening here
anyway
um last example I want to talk a little
bit about how prompts are generated
because I've I've been a bit
loosey-goosey with how I've explained
how it generates the responses the
continuations and it can generate like a
sentence or a paragraph or maybe just a
word
but in fact it does none of those things
uh it actually generates something
called tokens
um these are little parts of words
typically
the reason for that is because what the
model actually generates at the end of
the day is not text it's actually
probabilities for all the potential
tokens it might generate what are the
probabilities that one of those is the
next continuation of that prompt and
then it picks from the top few higher
probability of things it turns out that
just choosing the highest probability
every time doesn't work very well we're
not exactly sure why the producer's very
stale kind of text but if you add a
little bit of Randomness it actually
looks a lot more human-like that's what
people generally do
and that's the reason why it's tokens is
because it's not possible to assign a
probability to every world and every
word in the world especially when you
start considering things like proper
names which could be just about anything
so by reducing that probability of space
just down to tokens it's manageable and
it turns out to generate useful text at
the end of that
let's play around with that a little bit
um The Prompt I'm giving it here is an
unusual cat name is
and just to see what happens when it
generates a sequence of tokens Alonso in
this case
let's just generate one token at a time
Max tokens equals one
what do I get back I get nothing because
the first thing it actually responds is
a new line after the prompt if I
generate two
tokens I get two new lines because it's
the new line after the prompt and then a
space once I get to three tokens though
I get the first one let's generate an m
m as a token
let's try two tokens oh it's generated
Alaska that's two tokens Al and asker
and you notice that they don't follow
from each other because remember once
again the black box has no memory so
when I generated the four tokens it had
no memory that it just generated an M uh
previously but we can simulate things
like the API does by passing the
generated token back into the prompt so
stick it on the end of The Prompt
regenerate from that new prompt and then
iterate over that and so we'll be able
to see the process of it building up a
response token by token and this is one
of the fun things about playing with his
GPT models from R is you can program
math programmatic size is that a word
even
um this kind of uh experimentation
together
okay Jared this is your cue pick a
letter for me between a and z
l l okay so just to show that this is
happening dynamically The Prompt is an
unusually long name for a cat is L and
I've included one letter there to make
sure that the next token is in a new
line it's going to continue from the L
and then I'm going to Loop through I'm
going to first of all ask for a
completion of that prompt using the
DaVinci 2 model in this case
then I'm going to add the token it
generates back to that prompt
and then prints out the results and then
go back again so we're continually
cycling the generated single token back
into the prompt and seeing the results
so let's actually go ahead and run this
Loop and see what happens
all right this is a good one so you can
see it generating things prompt by a
token by token the first token was ulu
the next token was space Vaughn
the next token was space FL then uff
then en then bottom and then it doesn't
generate any more new tokens after that
um so it's generated and unusually long
time for a cat is Lulu Von fluff and
bottom and it's fun to try with
different starting letters to see what
you get there but I just want to show
you a little bit about what's happening
behind the scenes when the AI models are
actually generating the results uh token
by token and choosing them randomly
which is what gives it the variety in
the human-like nature of its results
all right that's it for the demo let's
do a wrap up
all right so we've seen GitHub co-pilots
in action you can use it from within
Visual Studio code and by the way the
visual studio team has done lots of
analysis of people using copilot um they
found for those people that have
co-pilot installed uh 40 of the code
that they write is actually generated by
copilot for them so it's saving them a
lot of time but more importantly it
means that as you're programming you can
spend more time you know actually think
about problems and thinking at a higher
level rather with the details of apis or
looking up code and so 75 of the
developers they surveyed felt more
fulfilled with their jobs using copilot
and 87 of them said it helped preserve
their mental effort
um unfortunately though co-pilot is not
free it is a subscription service of
GitHub it's ten dollars a month for
individuals at 19 a month for workers
within businesses and you can find the
details around that at the GitHub
website of course
lastly we also saw the open AI service
this is a new implementation of the open
AI models within Azure directly within
your Azure subscription the same
security the same models using the same
Billing System and it really makes it
easy to integrate these GPT models into
applications that you build within the
Azure system and as we saw you can get
access to that from any programming
language including art
so that's it for the presentation uh
once again if you would like to get
access to copilot within Visual Studio
code just use that link I have there
right there echo.ms slash get pilot I
provide all the demos scripts
information resources links uh
associated with this talk on GitHub at
the link that you see on the screen
right there it's been a pleasure I'm
doing this for you can always find me on
Twitter and if you have any feedback or
questions uh feel free to ask them now
uh and if you don't get a chance right
now because you're watching this on a
recording uh feel free to drop an issue
into the GitHub repository and I will
follow up from there all right thanks
for that and I'll hand it back to you
Jared
thank you very much David now we all
gave them a round of golf Applause but I
just want to say thank you um yeah I
really enjoy the talk
um so thank you very much for giving our
first ever and my car talk it's hard to
believe
yep I know I know when I see myself like
oh I'm gonna say David gave a talk in
it didn't happen though yeah
so I'm glad you finally gave it the
Legends finally happened
so the first question I saw asked was
can we use co-pilot in our studio
unfortunately you cannot
um copilot doesn't yet have an API for
other editors to plug into
um so it's just the four editors that I
showed you uh on the screen before I
remember what the last one was it's neop
thank you I was waiting to tell you that
yeah I haven't actually used neovin
myself I've heard so many people say I
should use it instead of them
but to be honest most of the time if I'm
in a remote sir well one second folks
sorry all right listen I've never used
neovism myself
um I use VI once and then I couldn't
escape from it and then I swore off it
off for ever since so if we know that's
the most
the most questions stack Overflow how to
exit Vim yes yeah yeah David Robinson he
also that is stop using it forever
yes yes so for folks that don't know
um David wrote a extension or plug-in
called ESS emacs speak statistics so you
can tell where he fell in the editor War
because I was going to say that most of
the time if I'm on remote server now I
try to use the vs code shell into
thermoserver to use it yeah
um so the next question we have in fact
I was doing that in the demo people
might have noticed that I was actually
writing all that within Linux within WSL
windows subsystem for Linux and I was
remoting over from my Windows desktop
into that remote Linux and everything
just works fine
nice and I've actually asked you a
question about this before I know like
so you use um WSL as your main
development and that's where you was
getting and everything so you don't
really do anything on the Windows side
oh except the user interface I mean I
use powerpointing is that local those
kinds of things and I like the hindering
system
um but in terms of if I'm coding I'm
using bash or ah so I want to be in
Linux for that yeah all right that's and
you've used you
use vs
chimery development environment
okay give me one second I'm gonna try to
remove the noise maker for one second
I'll be right back that's more questions
I vote hey Mommy
[Laughter]
yeah and feel free to ask me questions
about WSL um if anybody has questions
about that
um ever since that came out it's made my
Windows Experience much much nicer
because I've never been comfortable I'm
using any of the windows shell commands
I don't use Powershell I don't use CMD
Powershell it's a completely different
system than Bash
um so we'll see how long I get until the
little human comes back
um there's a question I'm going to
rephrase the question a little bit have
you found a way to sort of trick
um copilot it's using the native pipe
instead of the
um magritta pipe
oh no I haven't but on the other hand I
haven't tried
um I grew up with ah way before there
was even a tidy verse so even the
regular pipe is somewhat new to me
um and that's what I use in all of my
programming so I expect copilot has
picked up on that from my own code I
suspect I haven't tried this that if I
started using the native pipe it would
start echoing that back to me and it
also depends kind of how much data is
out there in the training day with
people using the native pipe which would
influence how often it does that as well
that was I was thinking because like I
guess that actually it's another
question how often is the model updated
to capture more recent developments that
is a good question uh the answer is the
underlying model itself not very often
like I mentioned earlier on it is many
months and many many millions of dollars
uh to retrain one of these models uh
that being said there's a person called
fine tuning which basically just
retrains the upper layers of these
models um so there are processes even
available in the
um the open AI service both on Azure and
in open AI where you can provide a new
Corpus of data and then sort of retrain
the upper layers of that model so it
will influence the way that it works so
that's one possibility that's kind of
left to the individual users though the
Microsoft doesn't do that for people so
it's like individualized you could point
it to your GitHub yeah
exactly but that's again that it is
possible
all right oh so you can't just point to
GitHub you actually need to go through
and train oh no no you need to provide
your your new or not your new training
data because it's built on the old model
so you essentially find you know with
some additional training data and that
might be a company's kind of own
knowledge base and then people within a
company then query that fine-tune model
and get answers that are that are
specific to not just the base model
itself but also the new contacts the new
Corpus that's been provided all right
that's cool yeah
um let's see
uh where is this all right what are the
licensing considerations and can this be
used for commercial work
absolutely if we were talking about
co-pilot here
um the code that is generated by copilot
is owned by you the person that
generated it's just for think about like
the way you do a compiler you know when
you use a compiler on source code the
binaries that are generated by that
compiler you earn those the same thing
applies to the code that's generated
um by copilot now that being said
remember all those things I said about
how you can't really trust these
generative AI models they can be useful
uh but do verify them and especially
when it comes to code do all the same
things you usually do with respect to
security and correctness you know build
tests around them do penetration tests
all those kinds of things you can't
assume that that code is going to be
perfect because it's drawn from the
training from the wealth of code that's
out on the web which itself is not
perfect
so can we are you going to have a George
Fox moment all generative models are
wrong but some are some are useful
maybe I'll use that as a quote in the
future
yeah yeah it's like quote by David Smith
quoting George box yes
all right I think hopefully that becomes
something
all right the next question is uh what
have you found co-pilot particularly
good at or surprisingly good at and what
do you find is surprisingly bad at
good questions
um the thing I find surprisingly good at
us is surfacing idioms and functions and
even libraries
that I wasn't aware of like when I was
uh when I used that janitor function
I hadn't used the genital library before
but I was doing some prompts around
cleaning data and one of them came up
with this Library janitor
um continuation I was like what's that
all about so I looked at it and then I
used it so it was like really useful to
me to learn how to do things
um same thing with a lot of the
Transformations that we're doing in the
data like I used to refer to I think I
have it here I used to refer to the
rstudio cheat sheets all the time and
now I don't need to because it just
tends to pop up those idioms for me as I
program
things that it's bad at
um when you start get into uh
complicated things or things that are
slightly different than standard idioms
it tends to
gravitate back towards the training data
you know what it's seen before so
sometimes you kind of feel like you're
fighting against it a little bit to say
do the thing that I want to do not what
the rest of the world has done and those
kind of situations you can actually turn
off the automatic prompts and just have
it generated prompt when you ask and
some people prefer to work like that
just say you know press a button give me
a prompt now rather than with every
keystroke I type
okay and it can't do that right now no
you can yeah that's an option on the
visual studio I forget exactly what
option is but you can make these say I
only generate a prompt when I ask
okay yeah
I wish you had done this maybe you have
or not I'd like to see a comparison
between the Tidy verse code it generates
and the data table code it generates
yeah that would be a good example and if
anybody wants to try it out you know
drop us a line or put a pull request to
some of the examples in the GitHub repo
or you could give a whole talk at this
Meetup about it if you got some cool
stuff yeah I can I don't use data tables
performance has never been any of my
concerns in any of my in my jobs I've
worked in ever so I much prefer readable
codes or performance code
now before we start a fight about data
table here
great photos of this tidy verse person
the staunch data table person at Rye
house after one of the conferences
arguing about this it's one of my
favorite moments um JD long captured on
bit photos so thank you forever JD for
doing that
um so yeah so going with what you're
saying actually about how it prompted
you of janitor or things you haven't
used before there's a bit of a lengthy
question so I'll try to get the the the
meat of it when you sort of um that uh
janitor it figured out the column names
for you yeah and this person is asking
well non-standard evaluation has
historically caused problems relenting
so in the example copies making
suggestions based that name the column
names which are not objects in the
environment and would not normally be
syntactically valid outside of a call to
a tidy verse function saying which of
these things are possible and then this
is lengthy I was I was first I'll ask
you before I ask his options how is that
possible how did it um figure out the
column names
without being able to look into the
object okay so first of all you actually
write it it's not looking into the
object it's not doing any active our
evaluation whatsoever and in fact I I'm
pretty sure it doesn't get even any
information about the our environment
because Visual Studio code isn't set up
to send it back to go by that I think it
might be for some other languages like
python but I don't think it is right
um
but remember all it's doing is
generating token by token things that
look good ultimately
um based on what it's done before so it
might generate absolute nonsense
um and you've got to be be aware of that
um I remember when I first played around
with co-pilot a couple of years ago now
um and I played around with the Penguins
data and I tweeted a little bit of a
video of an example and it wasn't until
later that I realized that the variable
names that are generated didn't even
exist in the data I think it was
something like Bill Waite was one of the
variables that generated there is no
build weight I think in the Penguins
data but it's generated those things
because Bill is something related to
penguins and weight was something
related to the data so just generated
that as a series of tokens so you've got
to be on the lookout to make sure that
um it's generating something that's
useful to you and quite often you'll
need to go back and do some editing
um I will confess that because I had
been practicing a lot with this
particular demo and visual studio code
was as I eventually run sending some of
that information back to the copilot
service for me it was actually learning
from what I had been doing before and
using some variable names so it was
actually doing a lot better than it
might do from a brand new setup
so that learning is doing from you it's
just for you like I won't benefit from
it learning about what you did yeah
that's just for me okay all right
cool
all right so the your answer to this
person's question essentially
um he gave three options what it could
have been one was looking at the data
frame which you said no reading from the
console and you said no about that the
third one is could have seen that this
is a commonly used data set and it would
have reached out saw that been used
before but from your pink Palmer's
Penguins example no it's just doing its
best to generate tokens
okay that works
all right uh cool then I will continue
on to other questions
um this is more of a getting started
question uh you sort of had a link at
the end that covered this the first part
of this a how do you sign up for copilot
and I think oh get co-pilots right
through your links right on the screen
yep yep then how did you get it inside
vs code working as a you know with uh
integrate into your console actually the
savings on said that link there is a
link to the extension in Visual Studio
code for copilot so once you've
installed that in extension it prompts
for you to sign in and GitHub and make
sure you have that all set up but the
extension is the easiest way to stop
okay
um I hope that answers that because
somebody says any other similar
questions about that okay
um you mentioned the generative Killer
Robots
and we know that Ours from New Zealand
where there's that song by Flight of the
Concords from New Zealand about the
humans are dead but the robots have
killed the humans
so are you is there any ethical concerns
about this AI coming true to find the
Concord songs
um I don't think so certainly not now
um uh yeah
a lot of these sort of long AI
conversations that people are posting on
the web
and if you read it with the ion of what
fiction might have
prompted this response given especially
the conversation history you can see it
drawing from things like movie plots and
novels and science fiction trips and all
kinds of things and you've got to
remember that it's not thinking it's not
it's not being creative it's just
generating sequences of words that are
like what it's seen before given the
prompt that it gave you so when you
think about what it's trained on some of
those responses that you see kind of
make a little bit more sense
well you know good writer borrows a
great writer steals yes and that's
what's happening so that's what's
happening cool
um
is the wrong word here because it's kind
of like what we do in our own creative
process you know we we we're influenced
by the literature we read and the
interactions that we have and there's
some amalgamation of that that is in our
output and in some sense and again not
to anthropomorphize these things but
it's really an amalgia um what's the
word I'm looking for a mix-up of all the
stuff that's been trained on conditioned
on the prompt that you gave right that's
why humans do things like you're not
writing you know Springsteen you just
sound hints of Dylan in him and somebody
got three within Dylan so yeah so people
on arguments there's a long
philosophical debate that we get have
here over many beers
yes it's fortunate we're not at right
house which doesn't exist anymore but
we're at some bar near the Meetup having
a conversation about this yeah David
just had to fly out to the east coast
one of the other meetups and come and
join us at the bar yeah
anything to get people over here in New
York City
so let's see there is a um
a question about actually there's a
follow-up to it let me just see where it
went uh where does this go oh can you
tell co-pilot no I don't like that try
again
I believe he can I think there's even a
keystroke for it I actually never use it
though I've seen people use it
um what I tend to do is just modify if I
get something that doesn't look like
what I write I have to try and modify
the contacts The Prompt I gave it the
previous comment or the previous landing
code
um I'll give it a little bit more
Guidance with the start of the code and
you saw me do that when I asked it for
an analysis of variants and use the
anima function which I don't like I use
I like the traditional aov function so I
just started writing the code like I
wanted to see and then I kind of got the
gist of it and followed on from there so
that's how I do it yeah I found that
interesting yeah when you deleted it or
ignored what it wanted you started
typing I don't think you even typed in
aov you just started like like so yeah
did that mean when you wrote that line
of code it had the context of the
comment above it also oh yeah the hat is
not just the the previous few characters
aligned it had actually it's a context
of most of the file I think I'm not sure
the details exactly what it gets sent
but it has a lot of context and often
surprising what it what it what it picks
up on
so that's a nice segue into another
question we had here
what's stuff's being sent over how long
is that store forward stored for how
long is it shared like what's the
Privacy implications of your prompts
which is your code going over there yeah
so if you I mean if you're in a company
you're working on proprietary code I
mean that code Snippets of it is
obviously sent to the the copilot server
for the purpose of generating the
prompts but after that they're discarded
okay yeah so it discarded like right
after the prompt is done yeah right
after the session yeah okay that's
that's a quick deletion all right yeah
and all the details of that are on the
there's a link that I provided in the
show notes um uh about some of the
policies and all the details are in
there
cool I think there's a bunch of
questions here about proprietary
confidential information stuff like that
yeah
Microsoft is obviously very sensitive to
that Microsoft's business is working
with you good with commercial companies
and so it's been designed with all that
in mind
license them
something to talk about a lot so I'm
also giving you a non-softball about the
licenses of the open source code on
GitHub that's being used and whether or
not
scanning someone's code is what are the
implications of that because I have a
feeling from what you've already said
the answer but like where have you seen
the conversations go about hey you use
my code as a training data I didn't say
you could do that
yeah well
um I'm not a lawyer so I can sort of
really answer this kind of in in detail
what I would Point folks to is there's a
series of FAQs on the on the GitHub
website around co-pilot I put a special
link uh directly in the show notes about
that that addresses a lot of those
questions
um like you know does co-pilot generate
code that exists in its training data
and the answer to that is most of the
time no but there are some examples that
people have uh seen where it generates
you know a few hundred characters yeah
they're voted verbatimism from other
characters some other code and that
generally happens either because you
know that idiom is represented in lots
of code across the web so it becomes the
most likely completion in that
particular case or sometimes it just
might be the only solution
um you know there's lots of places in
programming where there's just really
just one way to do it or that anybody
does it and obviously it's going to
generate that generated in that case
um there is an option in GitHub co-pilot
it's designed for exactly this this this
situation where people in commercial
companies just don't want there to be
any chance of anything representing
stuff that existed uh in the open source
database that it was trained on and so
it will automatically detect if code
that it generates is represented in the
training Corpus actually anything in
GitHub and will automatically not
generate it for you
okay then I have a slide I think at the
end of my deck I can probably pop that
up which kind of shows you how to do
that
so when this first command I remember
seeing screen caps of someone asking for
the fast inverse square root it was like
verbatim the the famous Doom code
including like the profanities in the
comments right yeah yeah that was one of
the examples that kind of prompted this
yeah exactly exactly there's a fun thing
to watch though let me tell you that's
very fun to watch but I certainly will
reiterate to anybody out there that kind
of has any questions
um about you know these issues around
um code completion and Licensing and so
forth um reach out to me I'd love to
chat with you and kind of hear about
kind of what those concerns are in your
particular situation and I can really
that relay them back to the GitHub team
uh I don't work at GitHub I work at
Microsoft but obviously we work closely
together and a lot of the slides in fact
uh came from some of my my friends over
in the GitHub team here
so talk about co-completions
doing a code completion of the path to
the file or even creating a function
name yeah in intellisense has been
around for a while so
what was going there was like an
old-fashioned intellisense or was every
code completion was that uh yeah every
completion you saw in that demo was
co-pilot I actually spent a lot of time
figuring out how to turn off all of the
intellisense and automatic function
header help and all that kind of stuff
because it got really confusing about
what was that wasn't
um but everything you saw in that demo
was Copart okay
that actually prompts uh another
question that I had up here is do you
have your vs code config for using R and
using copilot some Republican we can see
him and borrow from uh yeah it's it's in
um it's in this the notes for the
meeting
um I actually don't do a lot of
configuration for that but um I did
include some demo setup instructions in
there that show what extension extension
is to install in Visual Studio code and
what our packages are used to make those
demos work but it's pretty vanilla
everything that I used
okay and do you actually even include
turning off intellisense and that other
stuff I do actually yeah because I I
wanted those notes for myself and next
time I have to do this demo
because we had to talk a couple years
ago
um from the person uh kunren who created
the r extension for vs code
um and even still I'm like you need to
see config files because vs code is you
know if you really want to make it feel
like our studio it takes a lot of
configuration yeah um I confess I
haven't actually done a lot of odd
programming in a few months and so
coming back to that our extension has
come a long way uh it's much easier to
install and it is super powerful so I
was very impressed with how far that had
come along nice yeah it's I'm not sure
if he's the only one working on it still
or Microsoft's helping out but like it's
really great yeah yeah I was checking
out the GitHub repo and it's been very
active so I think there's quite a few
people working out nice good good for
those of you that don't know uh it's a
vs code extension to make working of R
and our markdown very easy uh if you go
to my hacker.org and search for vs code
or search for kenron Ken roon you'll see
you can find the talk you gave a few
years ago it's a whole thing that lets
you use the vs code like you just saw on
David using it's really nice
um so back to some questions then
when you hit the model API directly and
set the parameters to select the most
probable probable result can you set a
seed for deterministic outcomes
no I don't believe you can set a seed
um you do have some control over which
token is selected
and I believe if you set the temperature
parameter to zero it will always select
the most likely or the highest
probability token I haven't played them
around that without enough to know if
that's completely deterministic like I
don't know what happens if there's
multiple tokens that have the same
probability
um but it's that might be something to
try I haven't tried it myself though
okay
[Music]
um
so then how does copilot handle complex
or nuanced coding tasks such as
debugging or optimization
um that is a big question
um how does that handle I think I'd um I
haven't sort of gotten into that into
debt to be quite honest
um I've I write demo codes so I'm in in
the luxury position of never having to
debug it or write tests for it
um but I know the other people that have
um and I've certainly heard that um
people find co-pilot very valuable for
generating tests uh in all sorts of
languages so that's obviously something
that helps with the debugging process
there's you know generating those tests
and using that as part of your debugging
process
um you know when it comes to the more
complex things I'm not exactly sure to
be honest but if anybody has experience
with that they would like to jump in I'd
love to hear yeah I'd like to see that
because I was just seeing can we use
like uh either copilot or chat GPT to
generate a prompt for co-pilot or chat
GPD
ah that gets Distance by the long beer
conversation about what happens when
these models they're not trained in this
situation it's more about the prompt
Generation
Um but
um I will tell you that for the next
generation of models that have been
developed both of chat gbt and of codex
you know care is being taken actually
not to include AI generated content in
that training set to avoid that very
feedback loop
yeah
yeah you don't want to use the uh is
that even the statistical thing you
don't want an essential model yeah
so someone actually asks a nice segue
um what do you think about new what new
features do you think are coming or what
capabilities do you anticipate
um I would Point into a certain slide
let me show you in a slides because I
think I have one right at the end here
or
there we go if you go to githubnext.com
you can see lots of new features that
are coming for copilot uh one thing that
looks super cool that I haven't played
around a lot really a lot yet is
something called GitHub labs so you can
open up a little pain next to your code
highlights a chunk of code or a function
or whatever and then it will tell you in
English what that code does
oh wow yeah so that seems super cool and
useful that's in Labs right now so
that's going to see available to anybody
has GitHub if you install that new
extension
um and there's lots of very new cool
things coming as well uh they're coming
up with a version of copilot for the
shell prompts so the way you're show
programming or just typing show commands
it will suggest things in that lots of
other stuff as well
I would like to see this go second call
take code translated to human the human
is a prompt to generate new code yeah
yeah I'd like to see that
um okay so then there's just a few
comments going on in the chat about
there's a package called DT plier which
is for combining D player data table but
someone else is saying that tidy table
does an even better job than dph player
does so there's lots of cool things
going going back to our data table
discussion earlier okay
um one more uh question then we'll get
to a few giveaways and we'll come back
and maybe have another question
um you described it as a blurry jpeg of
the internet uh
which also may be considered a gif of
the internet
no because a gif is not lossy uh I
believe I mean like an animated gif oh
you know but you're right all right okay
is this a jig question or a serious
question
it's a great question all right yeah
yeah
Gotta Throw Some of those in there yeah
I like how you want to talk about the
lawsuit thing
all right so see if there's anything
left about uh for questions then if I
ask them all so if there's not then I'll
end this thing by talking about when we
start when I first introduced David I
said that he's been using R since before
it was called r
now I did not come up with that I saw
him tweet that once as a joke himself
but it's also true
because David has been using R for so
long he used it back when it was called
s
for those of you that don't know excuse
people in this community who are new to
r or older are
is derived from a language called s
invented at Bell Labs by John Chambers
1974 did I get that you're right damn it
do you know yeah 73 74 yep 33 74. it was
invented then at Bell Labs by John
Chambers and this is a breakthrough
language and it didn't become R it
hasn't ever be Kmart but R didn't become
a thing until the 90s I want to say 97
when two professors out of New Zealand
when and created R and then over time is
a whole shift over there including David
who made his way from s into R so if
you're ever wondering why we have S3 and
S4 objects it's because of s
so and that and David wrote one of the
first plugins for an IDE as I mentioned
earlier earlier at the beginning emac
speaks statistics which allowed you to
use it in emex
I've never once used emacs in my life
just like David's only ever once used VI
the exact revolutionary that was so and
for nothing else let's give David a huge
Applause for writing that and if we're
speaking at our Meetup and I said you're
not going to hear that pause it's all
going to be in emojis but thank you
David for your continuing contributions
to s slash R thank you Dad it's been a
real pleasure thanks for inviting me
this is a really fun talk to put
together you're all the first to see
this is the very first time I've given
this talk but I hope I get to give it
again so thank you very much yes yes
thank you for being here it's always a
great chance to chat with you I'm glad
uh everyone else can learn all this
great stuff from you thank you very much
all right have a good day everyone
bye-bye bye everybody